encontraron los países europeos una
alternativa para el gas ruso
alemania se ha propuesto crear una ruta
de suministro de gas con sus vecinos del
extremo oeste del continente
con mis colegas en españa portugal pero
también en una conversación con el
presidente francés y con el presidente
de la comisión europea
he defendido mucho que abordemos este
proyecto y seguramente habrá otras
conexiones entre el norte de áfrica y
europa para que podamos tener una oferta
diversificada
españa cuenta actualmente con 6
terminales de gas natural licuado para
procesar el gas que llega por el mar
pero sólo tiene dos enlaces de baja
capacidad con la red de gas de francia
que la conectan con el resto de europa
madrid ha estado presionando para
reactivar un proyecto de gasoducto que
la unidad con francia a través de los
pirineos sin embargo el primer ministro
de portugal dijo que francia está en
contra del proyecto a través de la
cordillera debido a preocupaciones
medioambientales pero sugirió una
alternativa
y eso del país la comisión europea ha
puesto sobre la mesa la posibilidad de
que si no es posible superar el bloqueo
con francia un kaiku frase de que el
oleoducto pueda tener una conexión
directa desde españa a italia llegando
al centro de europa por italia y no por
francia yo de también no profirió de
frase los dos países ibéricos reciben
gas natural licuado a través de un
gasoducto desde argelia y marruecos
también por barco desde países como
estados unidos y nigeria la guerra en
ucrania ha acelerado la búsqueda de
europa de alternativas a la energía rusa